vous souvenez pour la primaire de la
droite il ya eu un décalage entre ce
qu'ils ont déposés et ceux dont on a
constaté qu'effectivement il avait les
parrainages monsieur mariton qui
d'ailleurs il avait accepté sa retenir
comme le son fond la haute autorité à
droite a dit monsieur mariton peut pas
être candidat il n'y avait pas eu de
commentaires d'accepter les règles mais
et donc demain il y aura les candidats
il faut passer au débat des propositions
parce que on a vu un peu de polémique
sur des histoires de cotisation et
d'autre mais on a déjà un débat des
propositions ont évoqué au début cette
option celle de l'ancien premier
ministre manuel valls mais au cours de
son meeting benoît hamon en a fait et
donc tous à voir avec les marionnettes
accord qui à cuba qui est plutôt belle
ça est ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
maintenant ça suffit
arrivées climat et attendez il ya un
climat à gauche qui est un climat de
division
celui qui vient vous dire l' inverse sur
un plateau fait de la langue de bois ce
climat de division il peut conduire la
gauche être éliminé c'est pour ça qu'on
fait une primaire et si c'est la
primaire des chicaya et bien elle sera
un échec
les gens deviendront pas voter si c'est
la primaire des propositions tourner
vers l'avenir avec un débat loyal
normale sur ce que nous avons fait
pendant cinq ans au gouvernement
alors j'en suis convaincu les femmes et
les hommes de gauche sont au rendez vous
de la fin janvier comme ceux de droite
ont été au rendez vous de la fin
novembre